le cinéma américain pourrait connaître
une année record la période estivale à
elle seule a permis d'engranger des
recettes de 4 milliards et demi de
dollars
cette prothèse en donnant le cinéma
québécois n'est pas en reste avec le
mirage qui a franchi le cap des 2
millions $ on est à 6 % en avance
l'année passée par la fin juin
l'achalandage est en hausse dans les
cinémas et la tendance se poursuivra cet
automne on va avoir deux semaines de
flottement de flottement des recrues au
point même qu'on enfin deux points en
fin de semaine de la fête du travail
mais déjà partir du 18 septembre
on commence à en gros avec mme jouanno
et bruce et c'est une des premières fois
que le mois de septembre
by un gros mois de septembre
la rentrée marquera le retour au grand
écran de johnny depp méconnaissable dans
black mask bertreau note marc watney a
trouvé la mort hier en octobre ridley
scott le maître de la science fiction
nous arrive avec seul sur mars dans
lequel matt damon doit survivre quatre
ans sur la planète une on attend aussi
steve jobs ce deuxième long métrage sur
le visionnaire derrière à pau cette fois
danny boyle est aux commandes avec mac
os fassbender dans le rôle titre au mois
de novembre nous arrive enfin la
conclusion des rangers game avec
jennifer lawrence et trois ans après sky
sports daniel craig reprend les traits
de james bond suspense assuré avec
spectre dans lequel on verra à monica
bellucci léa seydoux et trois fois le
tour de tous vos malheurs est ce que le
cinéma québécois va trouver sa place vis
à vis et ses rivaux de taille la wii
l'articuler mal à garder je pense que
c'est un actuaire chez soi que le monde
de le voir le recrutement des
distributeurs indépendants mise aussi
sur le succès des films dc site une
année exceptionnelle pour le cinéma
québécois
on a des films quasiment tous les
week-ends des films extraordinaires
ça commence le 18 septembre avec paul à
québec le nouveau film de dany boon qui
pourrait techniquement un film québécois
mais quand même c'est un talent
québécois arrête de super g et comment
il est le nouveau film de philippe
falardeau du barça va t'en guerre et moi
je sors ville-marie le nouveau film de
guy édoin qu'il en casting
extraordinaire
l'année se terminera en lion avec le
film le plus attendu de 2015 le septième
star wars réalisé par jj abrams
le samedi
je sais aussi que dans le code de walt
disney qui maintenant propriétaire de
star wars et mise beaucoup disons que
n'importe qui qui aurait payé 4
milliards pour star wars vu remettre son
investissement donc on peut s'attendre à
elle pas qu'elle au niveau de la mise en
marché au niveau du film et sauf
comme si ce n'était pas assez tarantino
sera de retour en décembre avec le poète
on verra aussi de revenir alejandro
inarritu a tourné dans l'ouest avec
leonardo dicaprio ici tanya lapointe
radio canada montréal